foreign
okay so
yeah so this talk is gonna be about uh
grinding slower general flows in high
dimension and asymptotics and some
universality is mainly based on the
paper with
michael selentano and uh
that hopefully we
will post online
this week
starting point is for those of you that
were yesterday at uh
tradie uh
freddy's talk uh it should be clear that
we have a lot of tools so this this is
gonna be a talk about tools
and it's quite clear that we have a lot
of tools to reveal
with with the
problems in which we do activismization
possibly in high dimension
when the loss is convex
and the data gaussian
for instance gaussian function
comparison inequalities are a very
powerful tool
to deal with that
now
of course this has some limitations
first of all we know that often they
have not gaussian either because they
are not russian to start without because
we process them through a
few layers of real network
we know that often we are we are
interested in in non-convex objective
especially in in deep learning
and third we know that in the
overparadised setting we don't have a
single empirical risk minimizer but we
have many empirical risk minimizers and
so what we're really interested in is
the empirical risk measure to which
gradient flow converges
right now in some cases we can
characterize that like the mean norm
interpolator but in general we don't
know what is the implicit bias
so this is an attempt instead to you
know forget about this
directly
and arise directly
in some simple models uh gradient
descent or gradient flow and and you
know let me give you two examples that
are covered by by uh the kind of results
that i
uh
that i'll discuss
the first one is uh generalized linear
models
high-dimensional generalized linear
models but unlike in in classical
statistics and look at non-convex models
okay and what do i
have in mind i have in mind that i have
data
responses and feature vectors
and and perhaps these data are
some function of
noise variables
and then
the way we fit this data is we try to
minimize over some vector theta in rd
some loss function
that
is i'll use this scaling because this is
paper
scrub some regularized
[Music]
okay and and what i'm interested here in
understanding is for instance
because we said l0 gradient flow
that is
and this of course takes the form if you
practice
write down the derivative
this takes this form
memory the regularization term
where here l prime zero prime is the
first derivative of l zero the
derivative respect to the first argument
and okay of course there is a factor
that i forgot in my normalization and
this is applied component
twice right so this is one example we
might want to analyze
and you know
in this case we might want to know uh to
which which empirical risk minimizer
this this flow converges
professionally we might want to ask does
this converge
my optimum
yes which one
in what time
an example is
small neural networks
this is the the most baby example of a
neural network
and higher props of loss and zero
y i and then f of x i
theta
plus lambda
square and then here
f is
i'll put up something like this
and here the parameter theta
is
letter one
okay
so it's a matrix
okay
by n and our results by d sorry
and our results cover the case in which
k is fixed
and the dimension goes to infinity
okay and here of course we might want to
understand the same questions given a
certain d and then
and random data
yeah does this gradient send converge
gradient flow converge so of course
gradient flow is defined in the same way
as here
thus gradient flow converges to
global optimum which one in what side
okay and and you know sharp answers to
these questions are not known even in
very simple example
for instance one examples that
we studied
recently is
the negative percent throne
example that at least i would like to to
to understand and and in that case we
have
a line of theta
yes
let's see
my guy
in this case this l has this form
this hinge is zero for uh argument
bigger than t then kappa and
zero
so this is one exactly one specific very
simple example which i don't know the
answers to
these three questions
any question about these examples
because now i'm gonna introduce a
setting
which these are our special cases
and so the setting is the following
general flow
uh so we have a matrix so all of this
the property that depends on the random
matrix
and this would be the metrics of the
data
yeah
in this in this in this exception of in
this definition of glm that doesn't
include of course
yeah it's more general than what in
statistics you think
the normalization of theta or okay here
perhaps i can put square root of the
let's say
my normalization i'll put this and
here this is a special case right
and 0 if i call this so this is my
function let me give a different name
because
b of t
okay so this fits where l 0 of
z
y
is just b
of like that
defines uh
so the z
phi defines the the labels right
i'm not constraining the reality okay
we can constrain this but
we can put the negative and basically
constrain that okay here lambda
yeah so there is a little bit for to fit
exactly the strong constraint the hard
constraint one has to fiddle a little
bit around but
yeah
we can think of thoughts of the the
following maximize
another question
so this negative perceptron is basically
the problem of
you have a poly top that contains the
origin and you want to find the vector
with the maximum as to normal that point
all right
okay so so okay all of these as if the
property that are flows that depends on
the matrix on the random matrix that is
n by d
and uh
okay on a vector z
that is up in rn and then you know i
will have a sequence of functions that
are
our k times r
rk
for ht bigger than zero and then
the sequence of matrices lambda t
r k times k
and then you know the flow acts of
vectors that are
vectors that are d by k
and the the way it acts is in the
following way the
dt
is equal to minus theta t lambda t
okay so this is a matrix this is
minus d over n
x transpose
lt
x theta t
that
okay and this is you know the convention
is that this is applied
entry wise right so
l
t of
x data
that component i is just lt
of x i
theta
that's really
x i transpose times theta
okay the the so the previous should be
clear that there are special cases of
this for instance
the first case can be embedded in this
uh
by taking you know in fact k equal to
one has to take
now
let me assumptions assumptions for the
theorem
notice that this is more general in that
you know lambda can depend on time this
doesn't need to be a gradient and this
depends on time
okay and the assumptions
that we are going to make are the
following so the matrix x and g
as
okay that is the scaling
it is just to have a nice
normalization and then
this will be
iid
with
mean zero
and variance one
order one sub gaussian
and then okay some regularity on the on
the on the
on this coefficient lambda t
niche is bounded
which is
bonded
and
differentiable
uh with d
t so this you know the whole map t
uh
write it explicitly
differentiable
with
okay and then finally we look at the
proportional asymptotics
and
d to infinity
we then oversee
that
okay so of course each of these
assumptions excludes some interesting
cases but
so now i can state the theorem
the theorem is like this
so i state it in a simple to understand
form so for any
m and then it times t one
tm
and any function psi
r
k
m times r
r
t
the following happens so i look at 1
over d
sum over y 1 to
the
psi
theta i
1
i
infinity you know in the proportional
asymptotics
so what are we looking at here i'm
looking at
you know i take one coordinate one row
of this matrix this matrix is
evolving over time so i look at the
empirical basically the empirical
distribution of the coordinates
at multiple subsequent time
for instance of the case k equal one so
i look at
coordinate one at time t1
at time t2
this you know has some trajectory of
time t3 etc and i look at the joint
distribution of that
m time
and then i compute the limit of this and
i claim that this limit exists and okay
i'll describe the limit in a minute but
this is given by a certain
stochastic process that i call psi here
and the similar thing happens for
for the residuals
once okay if you have a
teta star
the same for
drops
okay and now so the limit i'll describe
it in a minute
where
uh
psi t
so this is a stochastic process and
rt is another stochastic process
and these are what
we call uh
the dynamical mean field
theory process
but okay before defining the limit i
want to just
you know
clarify or or make sure that it's clear
what is
this theorem talking about i look at you
know again
you know there is this whole vector that
evolves in in a very large dimension
this is this vector theta
i take one component i each component
has its own evolution over time
which generates his own evolution over
time i take one of this component
component i and i look at snapshots at
you know
m different times
and the claim is that the joint
distribution of these coordinates
converges to a limit that i can
characterize
and the same happens for the residual so
a special case this allows you to
compute things like
the estimation error
after
time t this is simply taking
upside the square function now i should
say that this is actually bounded lip
sheets you know what
but okay let's say that
you threshold that and yeah well or you
know you can
compute
stuff like this one
okay so very much as as in in the
in the case of empirical risk minimizer
with convex losses
for instance gaussian comparison
inequality allows me to compute
this kind of object by solving a set of
non-linear equations and we have
you know several dozens of examples of
that calculation this allows you to tell
something about you know gradient
descent and
okay so we we
moved the kind of beyond this thing and
we are trying
now
uh any question about this statement
yeah so so yeah you have kt
and i'm thinking of theta as a matrix
d
by k
right
and theta i okay so it's it's really the
i throw
of this okay
so now you're right because in when i
explained this example
when i explained this example i called
uh when i explained the the
the com the neural network example i i
called tita is the columns of this
and how i'm calling t ties the rows of
these matrix right so this is a very
skinny matrix
and what a you know constant number of
columns and diverging number of rows in
the neural net network example this
corresponds to a constant number of
neurons and i'm looking at the empirical
distribution of the rules
so this is telling you that basically
the empirical distribution of the rows
finite dimensional marginal set you know
many times at constant number of times
converges to
yeah so the second one
is is this case right so we we have not
only the process of thetas
but process also x times theta
so this is x theta t 1 component i
so i take the matrix
theta
i multiply that by x now this is what
this is a matrix that is
n
by k
and i'm looking at
again the rows of this
so think of k equal one if you want that
is the the and all the others are
basically
another question i realized that this is
props yeah
so you're taking here
so yes
what i'm assuming here for x is this
this this statement right
that x says
iid entries basically okay the scaling
is whatever you need to make things uh
be okay
and then it has iid entries centered
and otherwise have gaussian
now
okay natural question is can you
generalize this to some other nice
matrix model introducing some
correlation
i think so but okay this is the theorem
so far this is the theorem
right yeah so i'm gonna tell you the the
next
question but before i wanted to make
sure
let's make sense here because
basically again this is taking
one coordinate of my large vector
looking at the process that this
coordinate follows and claiming that the
process that is coordinate or the
process of a specific residual
converges to a limit and we have a
characterization of the limit
there exists a characterization
okay so
so the characteristic before giving the
characterization let me let me
i want to give you some
uh
summary of uh
what's nice and what's not nice about
the characterization so that you don't
have to understand the characterization
to to have an idea of what can we do for
you so this name first of all comes from
from physics of course
and i'll give you a few references this
is kind of a
by now classical topic in physics
uh
and uh okay what the one nice thing is
that you know this sci and these are
are defined are stochastic processes
in
order one dimensions
so we started with a very high
dimensional process and now we reduced
it you know for instance in the case of
the glm to a one-dimensional stochastic
process
uh
the stochastic process is that there are
no random have no random coefficients
if you think about it we started with
something like this that has some random
access
and then give you stochastic processes
for psi and r that are
stochastic but the coefficients are not
random
and
so these are two nice things
one not nice thing is that these
processes are not mercurial
and okay i don't know if good or bad but
okay they are parameterized
by five functions
that are called c theta
uh with functions of two times
theta
of two times
c l is a function of
r l is a function of two times
t it's a function of one time
and again as i said before describe
the dynamics
okay so so perhaps i i i can tell you
one word about why you should expect
that this is
not markovian is because if i
if i focus on a single coordinate of
this you know
vector of this very large vector say the
first coordinate
this will have some impact on the
all the other coordinates at some
subsequent time
and this later on will have back impact
on the first coordinate right
so if you start a markov process and you
take a low dimensional projection of
the markov process you get a non-markov
process the nice fact is that the markov
process that
we obtain i mean that one obtain is is
quite
uh it's not general but it's
quite specific one
now i can write it down
so the process that you obtain is the
following
but the process for psi is actually
gaussian in this case
okay
i can write it down
okay
so let me explain you
uh
so what is the deal here so as i said
the the process is parameterized by this
five deterministic function this is a
function of two times
function of two times et cetera i'm
thinking of k equal one for simplicity
but
in reality these are matrix value
functions
okay
and and what happens so you give me this
this file function i generate noise that
is covariance
cl
divided by delta delta t
and then
you know now i integrate this stochastic
differential equation this is a linear
stochastic differential equation with a
memory
sorry
oh sorry
yeah thank you
okay so you generate this
gaussian process with covariance cl
and then you integrate this this is a
linear differential equation is
stochastic in the sense that the noise
is stochastic but otherwise it's
completely
triggered
and then this gives you prop process
side
and the claim is that the coordinates of
this original gradient flow or whatever
flow you want
converge to
this psi
and gamma gamma is also
one parameter of the process
yeah now i'll tell you so so
an interesting part is that the
regularization term get added this extra
term and then you have a memory right
so so you have you know this is this is
no markovian for two reasons first of
all the noise is not brown emotion it's
not white noise and second there is a
you know this memory term
okay and the same fact for you know
similar thing for the response here you
generate w with the gaussian process c
theta
you plug it in here and then you
integrate
you solve this integral equation now
this integral equation is non-linear so
the process r is not the gaussian
process the process excites the gaussian
process
and the processor is not reduction
process
now how do you find these
five functions so any question about
this so this this defines completely the
process or completely defines the limit
of this
you know gradient flow
this proportional asymptotics if i give
you these five functions
[Music]
yeah this is a determination so so i'm
i'm driving
i didn't
so all of these functions so this
function is uh details
this is a gamma capital
the second one
the second means r oh
sorry
yeah so these are completely separate as
they should be because one is the
residuals and the other is the
parameters and they live in different
directions so
they basically live in different worlds
let's see over there is the noise from
the original
where is it
this is what this
oh yeah so this z is the same noise
right so
now there is a little gymnastic because
here i brought
the loss in terms of why not in terms of
the noise so you have to substitute this
here plug in there and then do the
gymnastics of the change of variables
[Music]
so gamma is a function that you know as
any of these five functions
i have still to tell you how to to
find
so
okay so how do i find these functions
this is
c
so this
they are a solution of five equations
these are fixed point equation
so c
theta
is the covariance of uh
s
transpose
uh see out yes
c transpose
r theta
yes
is
the anxiety
is the expectation
of the gradient with respect to r of n
what is the deal
so the way i think about is this as a
fixed point
equation
start with some
value for this function some guess for
this function
r
r l r theta c l c t time gamma
solve this stochastic differential
equation
compute this expectation or simulate the
stochastic differential equation compute
this expectation
and solve it
okay so this is of course uh
uh so so the question of studying this
equation is is you know future work but
as we saw this morning you know
theory three years ago was
we had very few applications now we have
a lot of them a few of them
and
hopefully the same will happen with this
so okay part of the proof is that this
this iteration that i just described
this a contraction so the solution
exists and
the contraction in a certain space so
the solution existed
one thing that we prove uh okay so one
thing that we can prove
is that so i started with this analogy
with with the gaussian minimax theorem
and okay let me start stating formally
theorem
you can look for solutions of this that
are stationary that depend on time
non-dependent time basically
they are fixed points so stationary
solutions
the system of equations
are
correspondence
uh
visionary points
of
uh the gaussian max theorem
regarding the quad now any of uh if you
take
you know
if you look at the case in which we are
minimizing for instance this loss
function there is a lower bound on the
loss that is the kind of thing that
freddie was doing yesterday that is
gaussian minimax theorem
and
this gives you a variational principle
and these fixed points are corresponds
to time independent solutions of this
so one one one nice thing about this
this old theories that allows you
to talk about the cases that are
over parameterized and in which you you
look several times the same data
so okay i don't know what i don't have a
lot of time but i want to
say a couple of more things first thing
about the history of this subject
so the subject
this type of equation were first written
in physics for for string glasses
starting with with
this key
was 1981
this was for the sk model
and since then there are you know
hundreds of papers in physics that
studies this kind of things
quite a few chrysanthemums criandolo
kurchan and and many others and and
recently people uh like uh you know
julio birolli
and lang lenka and florence
have studied they have used this type of
equation for
for ml
stars problems
so these kinds of give you gives some
rigorous theory for for that kind of
applications so they showed that in this
some cases you can study these equations
math there is also a mystery that is
more
more a bit more recent
this kind of equation for the sk model
in
1996
and you know with with dembo
patrick model with them boy in 2006
for the spherical
speed glass
and all of these are based on technique
that use in a crucial way the fact that
the matrix x is gaussian
so this is based on a large division
principle and this is based on
weak convergence and and
anger son of formula
and and very recently you know work on
non-gaussian mattresses has been very
recent
there is a paper by
amir
yanubatsky
and the author's iphone
it looks so 2000 i think it's 20.
looks at asymmetric xk sk
and there is a painter by denver
that looks at
some some system interacting diffusion
so it's a bit different
this is you know very so so this is for
non gaussian
is relatively sparser
and so this is regarding the history
of the subject
and perhaps one word about proofs
stop here
what about proof
so
the proof is very different from what
what these people do
we use a really pedestrian
approach uh
we discretize the flow
so we introduce a step size
so if you want if you are starting with
the gradient descent so
we we really look at
gradient flow we look really gradient
descent with step size eta
and then we show that
okay so this is something that
even before the discrete flow so the
script flow or discrete gradient descent
is is equal to an approximate message
passing algorithm
plus post-processing
so this is a class of algorithms that
have some some particularly convenient
problem property and there are
first-order methods
and if you apply some post-processes to
the rows of theta you get a discrete
gradient descent
and then
[Music]
use for this algorithms we have a lot of
results i've been working on this for
several years
use existing results
and in particular for this there is a
universality result
that we can leverage
so we leverage there is one one with the
with mos and biati and much large and
there is one that we actually use with
by way culture
is also very recent
and then okay basically all the work is
in to show that you can take the limit
of step size to zero basically the state
step size
uh doesn't matter
okay um
let me
finish with a couple of
of of questions that i think for future
study
question one is
okay so would be
interesting to look at x with correlated
columns
i think that something can be done
especially if you have this simple
range regularization
so for instance excite
zero sigma i think that there is
something that can be done in this case
and question number two uh
you know there are some concrete
consequences one case that we can do is
is
the the baby case is linear regression
okay i want to write it down
x transpose y minus x
theta t
this is just gradient flow with respect
to square loss in linear regression this
we can
analyze with this technology
not that exciting because this you can
do it also by linear algebra plus random
metrics theory if you know how to
compute
you know certain integrals of the
machine compass tool law but yeah still
you know
it's nice to to see that we can recover
those cases
uh probably in the next one next
interesting case is to do either small
neural networks of negative percentages
i guess i'll stop here
[Applause]
so what kind of
question about um
okay so this is one one thing
this is one example
let me give you the example
this is
not a particular admittedly not in a
particular exciting example from an
application perspective but i think it's
you know just for for uh
now take again this this negative
perceptron so you want to
let's say let's state it in this way
foreign
okay
and let's say that we take our let's see
i y i x i
plus minus one
times
zero
right
now one you know we have a
characterization of what is so angular d
equal uh
delta
and we know that opt of this problem
uh
converges to a certain you know
a large
[Music]
large delta behaves like something like
this so we know the value of opt of this
problem right so we know
that if you you know cut this in this
way and we start of zero we know the
value of opt
yeah
on delta right so so okay
here i should be sure precise i
scale things in the right way we know
the value of opt we know also that you
know there exists an algorithm that
achieve
some other value
it is strictly less than that
and now so if you do simulations with
this algorithm there is a linear
programming algorithm so this this
you try to achieve some radius r
this algorithm
has a nice threshold and this is
now if you run the gradient descent we
observed that in this specific algorithm
in this specific problem we observed
that
gradient descent
achieves a strictly
larger radio that us than this linear
programming
method
okay so the question is
okay so just to make the story short is
what is the value on this problem that
is achieved by gradient descent and one
way to to run gradient descent is simply
around gradient descent with respect to
minus theta square
plus sum over i
some barrier function of y i
x i theta
i say if i want to make it smooth i put
some barrier function here
inequality and then i run gradient
descent with respect to
this
thing
and then i want to
see
what point it reaches once i see which
point it reaches i can also try to
understand
the risk
so this is one case that i understand
you know at some level relatively well
now we can try to answer the same
question for
ideally for neural networks with a
constant number of neurons
and i would like to understand you know
for which values of n over d
i can achieve an interpolator i run
gradient descent
gradient flow starting a random
initialization
do i reach an interpolator
and second is
what is the test error of this
interpolator
right right right right yeah so so all
of these questions concern
one single time
yeah uh
yeah this characterization actually
multiple times is
just a bit because once you do the
theory it's natural to work with that
yeah i mean
it is the right object it's the right
additional questions
okay so
okay